1, 2, 3.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) 1, 2, 3. 1, 2, 3.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）1, 2, 3。1, 2, 3。
1, 2, 3.
1, 2, 3。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) 1, 2, 3. 1 2, 3. Sometimes, things aren't what you think they are, and people aren't who you think they are. That's what we're talking about today. I'm Ira Glass.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）1, 2, 3。1, 2, 3。有时候，事情并非如你所想，而人也并非你所认为的那样。这就是我们今天的话题。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
That is really weird, to hear you do that.
听到你这么说真是太奇怪了。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I'm here. This is actually Ira Glass. I'm sitting here with Fred Armisen.
我在这里。这其实就是艾拉·格拉斯。我和弗雷德·阿米森坐在这里。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi-- who's probably best known for Saturday Night Live, but also Portlandia. And I knew that you had worked up an imitation of me because we just happened to meet once.
嗨——他可能因为《周六夜现场》而闻名，但也因《波特兰迪亚》而为人熟知。我知道你曾模仿过我，因为我们恰好见过一次面。
Yeah.
没错。
And then you said something like, but you're not famous enough, so I have no use for this on television.
然后你说了一些类似“但你不够出名，所以我在电视上用不上这个”的话。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
I might have said that exactly.
我确实可能那样说了。
Yeah, and-- yeah.
对，而且……是的。
Well, after that, this writer at SNL, Christine Nangle and I, we figured out a way to turn it into a sketch that we could put on Weekend Update, the news segment on Saturday Night Live. By chance, NPR came up in the news. I think this was around the time that they were talking about cutting some of the funding.
好吧，那之后，《周六夜现场》的编剧克里斯汀·南格尔和我，想出了一个办法把它变成一个短剧，放在《周末更新》这个新闻板块里。偶然间，美国国家公共电台（NPR）上了新闻。我想那时正好是他们讨论削减部分经费的时候。
Here to comment on NPR'S troubles, the host of This American Life, Ira Glass.
接下来评论NPR困境的是《美国生活》的主持人，艾拉·格拉斯。
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
（笑声、掌声）
So I came out, and I'm wearing your glasses and a wig to look like you.
所以我出来时，戴着你的眼镜，戴着假发，看起来像你。
It's This American Life.
这里是《美国生活》。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I'm Ira Glass. Act 1. I was thinking the other day--
我是艾拉·格拉斯。第一幕。前几天我一直在想——
And the joke being that you were interviewing people at "Weekend Update."
笑话就是你在“周末更新”采访别人。
Ira, look, you can't bring other people on as your guests. You're my guest. It's just, your CEO just resigned. And now the Republican budget proposes cutting your funding completely. I mean, aren't you afraid that NPR might start laying people off?
艾拉，听着，你不能带别人当嘉宾。你是我的嘉宾。只是，你们的首席执行官刚辞职。现在共和党的预算提议彻底削减你们的经费。我是说，难道你不担心NPR可能会开始裁员吗？
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Act 2.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）第二幕。
Oh, boy.
噢，天呐。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Laid off? No guts?
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）被裁员？没种？
So this never made it to air. This is just the recording from the dress rehearsal. Why didn't it make it to air?
所以这段从未播出。这只是彩排时的录音。为什么没能播出？
Who knows? It might have been a little unwieldy.
谁知道呢？可能稍微有点棘手。
So if people want to watch that, the entire video, we have a link at our website. Anyway, so we invited you here today because the theme of this week's show is doppelgangers. The show is about doppelgangers, about people who are doubles or lookalikes. And I realized that because you had worked up this imitation, you could co-host as my doppelganger in this room, in this studio, during this broadcast. This is an audience who will actually know who you're playing.
如果人们想看那个完整的视频，我们的网站上有链接。不管怎样，我们今天邀请你来是因为这周节目的主题是“分身”。节目是关于分身，关于那些替身或长得像的人。我意识到，因为你曾模仿过我，你可以在这次广播中作为我的分身跟我一起主持。这里的观众确实知道你在扮演谁。
Yes, this is the right venue for it.
是的，这是最好的场地。
So if you're ready, that's what we'll do.
如果你准备好了，那我们就这么做。
Sure. And another way to look at it is, you're co-hosting with me, that this is my show.
当然。换个角度看，是你跟我一起主持，这是我的节目。
Exactly.
没错。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And that's what we're talking about today. I'm Ira Glass.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）这就是我们今天谈论的内容。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
All right, so let's go to this copy. So we have some copy for today. OK. That's this one. And let's go to there. And let's just-- why don't you start?
好的，让我们进入文稿。我们今天有一些文稿。好吧。就是这一段。让我们去那里。让我们……你为什么不开始呢？
OK. (IMITATING IRA GLASS) Today on our show-- today on our show.
好的。（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）今天在我们的节目中……今天在我们的节目中。
Let me think. I'm just thinking about how I would do it. I would go, today on our show--
让我想想。我正在想我会怎么做。我会说，今天在我们的节目中——
Oh, yes. That's better. OK. (IMITATING IRA GLASS) Today on our show--
噢，是的。那样更好。好的。（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）今天在我们的节目中——
We have two stories of supposed doppelgangers.
我们有两个关于所谓“分身”的故事。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) --we have two stories of supposed doppelgangers. And we try to figure out the truth of them.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）——我们有两个关于所谓“分身”的故事。我们试着去探寻它们的真相。
Do I sound that nasal?
我的鼻音有那么重吗？
Maybe.
也许吧。
And we try to figure out the truth of them.
我们试着去探寻它们的真相。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And we try to figure out the truth of them.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我们试着去探寻它们的真相。
One concerns two men who've never met--
一个是关于两个从未谋面的男人——
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) The other, two animals who never meet.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）另一个，是两个从未相见的动物。
I think you should do the next part because it's so-- do you want to hear me do it first? Or do you just want to do it? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
我觉得你该说下一部分，因为它太……你想先听我来一遍吗？还是你想直接说？来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Distributed by Public Radio International.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）由公共广播国际公司发行。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I feel like a Muppet. Why does it make me feel like a Muppet, Fred? [LAUGHTER] Seriously, why--
我感觉自己像个布偶。为什么这让我感觉像个布偶，弗雷德？（笑声）说真的，为什么——
I think you could be a Muppet. I don't know why they don't have a Muppet of you.
我觉得你完全可以是个布偶。我不知道为什么他们没做一个你的布偶。
From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life--
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》——
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life--
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》——
--distributed by Public Radio International.
——由公共广播国际公司发行。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) --distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）——由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
And I'm Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
So Fred, you want to start Act 1?
那么弗雷德，你想开始第一幕吗？
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) OK, Act 1, Dead Ringer. We start today with a story of physical resemblance, not of a person, but of a food.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）好的，第一幕，“冒名顶替”。今天我们从一个关于外形相似的故事开始，不是人，而是食物。
A quick warning that if you're squeamish or averse to graphic images of food, there's going to be some of that in this report. Here's Ben Calhoun.
顺便提醒一下，如果你是个敏感的人，或者对食物的写实图像感到反感，这篇报道中会有一些。这是本·卡尔霍恩。
I first heard about this whole thing in an email. It came from a listener, a woman named Emily Rancer. She works in the food industry.
我第一次听说这件事是在一封邮件里。它来自一位听众，艾米丽·兰瑟。她在食品行业工作。
And the letter Emily wrote was about a story she'd heard from a farmer. The farmer who told her this is apparently a person of some standing in the pork industry. And admittedly, I don't know the first thing about the pork industry, but he's in charge of a pork-producing operation that spans several states.
艾米丽写的信是关于她从一位农场主那里听到的故事。告诉她这个故事的农场主显然在猪肉行业里颇有地位。平心而论，我并不懂猪肉行业，但他负责的猪肉生产业务跨越了好几个州。
The story he told Emily went something like this, a while ago, he was visiting a pork processing plant in Oklahoma. He's walking through it with a friend, a guy who managed the plant, actually. And at some point, he saw boxes stacked on the floor, labeled "artificial calamari."
他告诉艾米丽的故事大致是这样的：不久前，他参观了俄克拉荷马州的一家猪肉加工厂。他和朋友一起走进去，那是厂里的负责人。在某个点，他看到地上堆着标有“人造鱿鱼”字样的箱子。
He stood there, wondering for a second. And then he asked his friend, what's artificial calamari? Bung, his friend replied. It's hog rectum, rectum that would be sliced into rings, deep fried, and boom, there you have it.
他站在那里疑惑了一秒。然后他问朋友，什么是人造鱿鱼？“猪直肠，”他的朋友回答。“把它切成圆圈，油炸，砰，你就得到了。”
OK, if I can, let me just narrate for you what this would mean. It would mean that in restaurants everywhere, right this second, people are squeezing lemon wedges over crispy, golden rings, and dipping the rings into marinara sauce, and they're eating hog rectum.
好吧，如果可以的话，让我为你叙述这意味着什么。这意味着在各地的餐馆里，就在这一秒，人们正在把柠檬挤在金黄酥脆的圆圈上，把它们蘸进番茄酱里，而他们吃的是猪直肠。
Now, they're chewing, satisfied, and deeply clueless. It's payback. It's payback for our blissful ignorance about where our food comes from and how it gets to us. It's amazing. And it's perfect.
现在，他们正在咀嚼，感到满足，却对此一无所知。这是报应。这是我们对于食物来源及其加工过程的无知所带来的报应。这太惊人了，也太完美了。
But it also seems like it couldn't possibly be true. So I called up the farmer to talk to him personally. I wanted to hear it firsthand. And the farmer confirmed the story-- the entire thing, the boxes, the bung. But when I asked him to go on the record, to tape an interview, and gave his name here, on the radio, he very politely declined, which seems suspicious, right?
但这也听起来不太可能是真的。所以我打电话给那位农场主想亲自聊聊。我想亲耳听听。那位农场主证实了这个故事——整件事，箱子，直肠。但当我请他正式录音，把名字放在电台上时，他很礼貌地拒绝了，这看起来很可疑，对吧？
When I asked him why, he said he'd spoken with his girlfriend about it, and she suggested that he should think about the words that he wanted to come up when somebody Googled his name. This was all fine, though, because he referred me to the real expert, the guy who gave him the tour of the hog processing plant. And that guy, he agreed to talk.
当我问他为什么时，他说他跟女朋友商量过，她建议他想想当别人在谷歌上搜索他的名字时，他想展现什么样的词条。不过这没关系，因为他把我介绍给了真正的专家，就是带他参观猪肉加工厂的那个人。那个人同意谈谈。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
Hello.
喂。
Hi, is this Ron?
嗨，是罗恩吗？
Yeah.
是。
Yeah, this is Ron Meek, meat processing plant manager, presently residing in Mountain View, Missouri, where he runs an organic beef processing plant there called Beyond Organic. If the story really were true, Ron would have been the guy who explained to the farmer what was in those boxes.
这是罗恩·米克，肉类加工厂经理，目前居住在密苏里州的芒廷维尤，他在那里经营一家名为“Beyond Organic”的有机牛肉加工厂。如果这个故事是真的，罗恩就是那个向农场主解释箱子里装的是什么的人。
The boxes are 10-pound boxes, and they were all-- they cut off so much of it, maybe a 10- or 12-inch piece of the bung. And you know what it looks like? This looks like, after they're cleaned and washed and everything, they just look like a bunch of big noodles in a box, is all it looks like.
那些箱子是10磅装的……他们切下了很大一段，也许有10到12英寸长的直肠。你知道它看起来像什么吗？清洗干净之后，它看起来就像一箱大面条，看起来就是这样。
But specifically, the labels that said "imitation calamari," where did you personally see the "imitation calamari?"
但具体来说，标签上写着“仿制鱿鱼”，你个人是在哪里看到“仿制鱿鱼”字样的？
Oh, I've seen a label say that. That's all I was told by the people that told me that. The people I work for, they told me that.
噢，我确实看到过那样写的标签。这就是告诉我的人所说的。雇佣我的人，他们是这么告诉我的。
Oh, the people that you worked for told you that it was used for imitation calamari?
噢，雇佣你的人告诉你它是用来做仿制鱿鱼的？
Right.
对。
And is there any possibility that you think that when they were explaining this to you, that they were kind of having you on a little bit?
你认为他们向你解释这些时，有没有可能是在跟你开玩笑？
Having me on?
开玩笑？
Yeah, like--
是啊，比如——
Bull-[BLEEP] me?
胡扯我？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I wouldn't think that. But it could be 5%. It could have been that. But I seriously doubt it.
嗯，我不觉得。但可能有5%的可能。也许是那样。但我深表怀疑。
OK, just to give a little better picture, a pork bung-- and "bung" is the actual industry term for it-- is long and floppy and ugly. At one end, it widens out into this more bulbous shape, like a pink, wrinkly pear. That's the rectum. At the other end, it narrows into a soft, pinkish-white tube.
好吧，为了更清楚地描述一下，猪直肠——“bung”是业内实际术语——又长又软，很难看。一端变宽，形状更圆，像个粉红色的、皱巴巴的梨。那就是直肠。另一端变细，成了一根柔软的、粉白色的管子。
I know, it sounds gross. But also, consider, we are a nation that eats more than a billion pounds of sausage every year, billion with a B. Maybe you like liverwurst or capicola or summer sausage with a natural casing. Then you, like me, have eaten bung-- stuffed, dried bung.
我知道，听起来很恶心。但也得想想，我们国家每年消费超过十亿磅香肠，是“十亿”的十亿。也许你喜欢肝泥香肠、卡皮科拉或者带天然肠衣的夏季香肠。那么，你像我一样，吃过直肠——填充的、干制的直肠。
A lot of brats and Italian sausages are stuffed in intestine. So if you eat those regularly, you pretty much live up the street from bung. So why does the idea of a fried ring of bung just feel grosser? Well, partly, it's the visual, right? When you see that little ring of calamari, you don't want to picture it in the context of a pig's behind.
很多德国香肠和意大利香肠都是用肠衣填充的。所以如果你经常吃那些，你其实就住在直肠隔壁。那么为什么炸直肠圈的念头感觉更恶心？嗯，部分是因为视觉效果，对吧？当你看到那个小小的鱿鱼圈时，你不想把它和猪屁股联系在一起。
Then there are all the people who don't eat pork, period. Ron said there's also another reason.
此外还有那些根本不吃猪肉的人。罗恩说还有另一个原因。
Just because of the word "bung," probably. I mean, people don't just want to jump up and say, man, I'm going to eat me some bung tonight. I mean, that's just the way it is.
可能就是因为“直肠”这个词。我是说，人们不想突然站起来说，伙计，我今晚要吃点直肠。我是说，情况就是这样。
But the big question, the question you've been thinking about since we got on this topic, have you or I eaten imitation calamari, bung dressed up as seafood? Well, Ron didn't know. He said his plant exported a lot of their bung to Asia. But he just didn't know much about whatever happened after it left the door. So he could only speculate. Anything, he said, would be a wild guess.
但最大的问题，我们谈论这个话题时你一直在思考的问题：你或我吃过仿制鱿鱼吗？把直肠伪装成海鲜？好吧，罗恩不知道。他说他的工厂把大量的直肠出口到亚洲。但他对这些东西离开工厂后发生的事了解不多。所以他只能猜测。他说，任何说法都只是盲目猜测。
So I turned to people who would know. Is pork bung being falsely peddled as calamari? I called the USDA. The USDA's Food Inspection Service issued the following statement to me. "Products we inspect, including those derived from pork, must be accurately labeled and cannot purport to be a product of another species."
所以我转向了那些应该知道的人。猪直肠被虚假冒充为鱿鱼了吗？我联系了美国农业部。美国农业部食品检验局给我发表了以下声明：“我们检验的产品，包括猪肉制品，必须标注准确，不能冒充其他物种的产品。”
So it's against the rules. But people break the rules. A recent study of seafood by a group called Oceana used DNA testing, and found that all across the country, fish is regularly being labeled as other species in restaurants and in grocery stores, escolar sold as white tuna, Pacific rockfish being fraudulently sold as snapper.
所以这是违规的。但人们会违反规定。最近由一家名为Oceana的组织进行的一项海鲜研究，使用了DNA检测，发现全国各地的餐馆和杂货店里，鱼类经常被标为其他物种：无须鳕被当成白金枪鱼卖，太平洋岩鱼被欺诈性地作为红鲷鱼销售。
In Miami, more than 30% of fish was being sold as something it wasn't. In New York, the number was 39%, Boston, 48%, Los Angeles-- are you ready? 55%, 55. That means if you order fish in LA, you are most likely eating a species you did not order.
在迈阿密，超过30%的鱼类名不副实。在纽约，这个数字是39%，波士顿48%，洛杉矶——准备好了吗？55%，55。这意味着如果你在洛杉矶点鱼，你很有可能吃的是你没点的物种。
In other words, seafood substitution is rampant in this country. And depending on where you live, from what I can tell, you can get cleaned hog bung for about half the price of clean squid. So there would be money in it if you could pull off the switch. And as best as I can tell, were you to do this, you would not be caught.
换句话说，海鲜替换在我国很猖獗。根据你的居住地，据我所知，你可以以清洁鱿鱼价格的一半买到干净的猪直肠。所以如果你能成功转换，是有利可图的。而且据我所知，即使你这么做，也不会被抓到。
A lawyer who's familiar with this area of law and regulation told me, once bung leaves the plant, there's a variety of agencies and entities that would be in play-- USDA, FDA, state, and local government. But ultimately, he said, the regulation we have is not designed to catch an offense like this. It's aimed mostly at sanitation and food safety.
一位熟悉这一领域法律和法规的律师告诉我，一旦直肠离开工厂，就会有各种机构和实体参与——农业部、食品药品监督管理局、州政府和地方政府。但最终，他说，我们现有的监管并非旨在查获此类违法行为。它的重点主要在于卫生和食品安全。
So bottom line, the lawyer said, if somebody wanted to do it, chances are, they'd get away with it. So is someone out there doing this? Well, for weeks, I looked for an answer. The USDA says they've never heard of anyone trying to pass pork bung as squid or any other species.
所以底线是，律师说，如果有人想这么做，他们很可能会侥幸逃脱。那么有人在这么做吗？几周以来，我一直在寻找答案。美国农业部表示，他们从未听说过有人试图把猪直肠当成鱿鱼或任何其他物种来售卖。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
I contacted the National Restaurant Association, the National Pork Producers Council, the National Pork Board--
我联系了全美餐馆协会、全国猪肉生产商委员会、国家猪肉委员会——
Hello?
喂？
--a squid fisherman's association--
——一个鱿鱼渔民协会——
Good afternoon.
下午好。
--Cisco and other big food and restaurant supply companies.
——思科以及其他大型食品和餐饮供应公司。
It's hog what?
它是猪什么？
Bung, hog rectum.
直肠，猪肛门。
Oh, my gosh.
噢，天呐。
That's the executive director of the California Wet Fish Producers Association. But the answer was pretty much always the same, nobody had heard of it. But almost to a person, they added that that doesn't mean it's not happening somewhere.
那是加州湿鱼生产商协会的执行董事。但答案几乎总是一样的，没人听说过。但几乎每个人都补充说，这并不意味着它不在某处发生。
Ron Meeks said a lot of the bung from his plant got exported. So my next call was to the US Meat Export Federation, which confirmed that, quote, "the main destinations for pork bungs are China, Hong Kong, Japan, Taiwan, Korea, and the Philippines. They are mainly used for processing. But we are aware of some uses in soups and certain entrees. We are not aware of them being used as a substitute for calamari, but it's not impossible," unquote.
罗恩·米克说他工厂的很多直肠都出口了。所以我的下一个电话是打给美国肉类出口联合会，他们证实了这一点，引用如下：“猪直肠的主要目的地是中国、香港、日本、台湾、韩国和菲律宾。它们主要用于深加工。但我们知道它们在汤和某些主菜中的一些用法。我们不知道它们被用作鱿鱼的替代品，但并非不可能，”引文结束。
So over the past few weeks, I've called Asian food suppliers, people who live in, work in, and eat in those countries. I talked to a woman named Corinne Trang, who's written an overarching compendium of Asian cuisines. I've talked to academics at NYU and Haverford and USC and Harvard. I've reached out to chefs who know Asian food.
所以过去几周，我给亚洲食品供应商、住在那些国家、在那些国家工作和吃饭的人打了电话。我和一位名叫科琳·特朗的女士聊过，她写过一本亚洲菜肴的综合纲要。我跟纽约大学、哈弗福德学院、南加州大学和哈佛大学的学者谈过。我联系了了解亚洲美食的厨师。
The answer, again, always similar-- never heard of it, but it's possible, partly because bung doesn't have such a complicated reputation in Asia, where it has to be some kind of secret ingredient, like it does here. On the other hand, though, people pointed out that in Korea and Japan, you can't get more than a few hours from the ocean. Squid is cheap and it's readily available. You'd only eat a substitute if you wanted the substitute.
答案再次相似——没听说过，但有可能，部分原因是直肠在亚洲没有那么复杂的名声，它不需要像在这里那样成为某种秘密配料。然而另一方面，人们指出，在韩国和日本，离海洋最远也就几个小时。鱿鱼既便宜又容易买到。只有当你想要这种替代品时，你才会去吃它。
Generally, people said, if the switch was happening somewhere, they'd guess China. Eventually, I found my way to this guy, who I was really excited about, someone who I thought might have my answer. He was, get this, an anthropologist who lived and worked in China for 40 years, where he studied food, and specifically, meat.
人们普遍表示，如果这种交换在某处发生，他们会猜测是中国。最终，我找到了这个人，我对此非常兴奋，我认为他可能有我的答案。他是一位在中国的大学里生活和工作了40年的人类学家，他专门研究食物，尤其是肉类。
When I talked to him, though, he made two points. Point one, my question about this happening in Asia was racist. Even just asking the question was racist because it plays on ignorant stereotypes about other cultures eating things that we perceive as weird. Point two was that Ron Meek, my guy from the pig plant, Ron was pulling my leg. And he was getting away with it because I was a dumbass.
但当我跟他交谈时，他指出了两点。第一点，我关于这在亚洲发生的问题是种族主义。仅仅是问这个问题就是种族主义，因为它利用了关于其他文化吃我们认为奇怪东西的无知刻板印象。第二点是，罗恩·米克，我那位从猪肉加工厂找来的人，是在逗我玩。而他能得逞是因为我是个白痴。
He told me more than once that I should, quote, "find something worthwhile to do with myself." When we ended our conversation, he told me that he was refusing to even dignify what I was doing by appearing on the radio or by letting me use his name.
他不止一次告诉我，我应该“找点有价值的事情做”。当我们结束谈话时，他告诉我，他甚至拒绝通过上广播或让我使用他的名字来证明我所做的事情的正当性。
OK, so to respond to his points one by one, first, am I racist against Asians? Well, I'm half Chinese. My mom's Chinese. Like anyone, I've had the occasional issue with my mother. But this has not been one of them. We grew up eating chicken feet and fish eyes. And I think it's possible to raise the question of who eats what without being racist.
好吧，逐一回应他的观点。首先，我对亚洲人有种族歧视吗？嗯，我有一半中国血统。我妈妈是中国人。像任何人一样，我和母亲偶尔会有问题。但这并不是其中之一。我们从小吃鸡爪和鱼眼。我觉得提出谁吃什么的问题而不带有种族主义是可能的。
His second point, though, that Ron Meek was pulling my leg, I mean, the guy was still an expert on meat in China. So I called Ron back.
不过他的第二点，即罗恩·米克在逗我玩，我是说，那个人毕竟是中国肉类方面的专家。所以我又给罗恩打了电话。
All right, shoot me some questions, dude.
好的，尽管问我问题，老兄。
I told him the whole thing, about the anthropologist, about what he said.
我把整件事告诉了他，关于那位人类学家，关于他说的那些话。
I guess, I mean, the only thing I want to ask you is, are you messing with me?
我想，我是说，我唯一想问你的是，你是在耍我吗？
No. I mean, that was what my boss told me. I was like, what the hell do we save these hog bungs for? He says they use them for imitation squids and stuff like that.
没有。我是说，那是我的老板告诉我的。我当时问，我们为什么要留这些猪直肠？他说他们把这些用作仿制鱿鱼之类的东西。
So in your heart of hearts, you believe it?
所以在你的心底深处，你相信它是真的？
Yeah, man, I mean, I ain't going to sit here and tell you things that, they're just bull-[BLEEP], and play with you, when I'm just going off of my knowledge of saving hog bungs. I mean, you got to think about how far advanced slaughterhouses are, especially big ones, that want to make every penny count.
是啊，伙计，我是说，我不会坐在这里跟你胡扯，逗你玩，我只是根据我保存猪直肠的知识说的。我是说，你得想想屠宰场有多先进，特别是那些大厂，它们想赚取每一分钱。
The one I worked at, you bring the pigs in, you stun them, then you stick them, and the blood goes off into a trough, and it goes down. And it's vacuum sucked out of there with a vacuum, into centrifuges. And they separate the blood from the blood plasma. And they save that.
我工作的那一家，你把猪赶进去，电晕它们，然后刺穿它们，血流进槽里，流下去。它是用真空吸出来的，进入离心机。它们把血从血浆中分离出来。它们保存那个。
I mean, they save the lungs. They save the pancreas. They save the spleens. They save the hearts. The only thing left, by the time it's all said and done, is a skull and jawbones. I mean, you can be an anthropologist all you want. And if you don't work in a processing plant, you don't know [BLEEP].
我是说，它们保存肺。它们保存胰腺。它们保存脾脏。它们保存心脏。到最后，只剩下头骨和颌骨。我是说，你尽可以当人类学家。如果你不在加工厂工作，你什么都不知道。
I contacted the plant Ron worked at, where this happened. And for what it's worth, they backed him up. They said their sales team had heard of people eating pork bung as imitation calamari, though they hadn't witnessed it firsthand or heard it directly from a customer. It was all hearsay.
我联系了罗恩工作的工厂，那是事情发生的地方。不管有没有用，他们支持他的说法。他们说他们的销售团队确实听说过人们把猪直肠当作仿制鱿鱼吃，尽管他们没有亲眼见过或直接从顾客那里听到过。这都是道听途说。
So at the end of all this, I still had no proof that anyone was passing off bung as squid. And then I realized I hadn't asked the more basic question here. Could bung do it? Could it pass as calamari? And that question led me to a guy named Eddie Lin. Eddie Lin has eaten a lot of bung, at least a hundred times, he said, probably more. Eddie has an extreme food blog called "Deep-End Dining" and an online TV show called Kamikaze Kitchen.
所以这一切结束时，我依然没有证据表明有人把直肠当鱿鱼卖。然后我意识到我还没问这里更基本的问题。直肠能行吗？它能冒充鱿鱼吗？这个问题引导我找到了一个叫埃迪·林的人。埃迪·林吃过很多直肠，他说至少有一百次，可能更多。埃迪有一个名为“深端餐饮”的极限美食博客和一个名为“神风厨房”的网络电视节目。
I can definitely see a resemblance, texture-wise.
我绝对能看出它们在质地上的相似之处。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah, yeah, definitely. There's a rubbery texture, sort of like a calamari.
是的，是的，绝对有。有一种橡胶质感，有点像鱿鱼。
Huh.
哈。
But you would really have to get rid of that, needless to say, foul flavor and odor from the bung.
但毫无疑问，你真的必须去掉那种直肠特有的腥臭味。
Somehow, I hadn't figured that the bung, once it was scrubbed and rinsed and cleaned with steam, that it would still taste like, you know.
不知何故，我没预料到直肠在被冲洗干净并用蒸汽清洁后，还会尝起来像那个……你知道的。
So yeah, you would definitely have to do some major, major blanching-- or brining. I meant brining.
所以是的，你绝对得做一些重大的、重大的焯水——或者盐渍。我是说盐渍。
Uh-huh, to just to try and leach those flavors out of there?
嗯哼，就是为了试图把那些味道洗掉？
Yeah, I mean, those flavors have been marinating in that pig for quite a while. So--
是啊，我是说，那些味道已经在猪身上腌制了相当长一段时间了。所以——
A lifetime?
一辈子？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
He thought it wouldn't be easy, but he thought it could be done. And there was only one way to tell if he was right, to cook up some bung and eat it. And if the taste was overwhelming and the texture was all wrong, well, then I'd have my answer. And at this point, I'll be frank, I started to root for the bung.
他认为这不容易，但他认为可以做到。要判断他说得对不对，只有一个办法，那就是烹饪一些直肠吃掉。如果味道让人难以忍受，质地也完全不对，那我就有答案了。到这时，坦白说，我开始为直肠加油了。
I realized that this is not a story about fraud. It's not a bait-and-switch story. It's a story about possibility. It's classic rags to riches. It's about whether a cut of meat, perhaps the lowliest, most malignable cut of meat in America, might somehow, in at least one place on the planet, be dipped in the redemptive oils of the great culinary equalizer that is the deep fryer. And it might emerge transformed, no longer an outcast, but instead, hair combed, clean-shaven, in a suit and tie. It might walk reborn onto a table.
我意识到这不是一个关于欺诈的故事。这不是一个诱骗的故事。这是一个关于可能性的故事。它是经典的“从贫穷到富有”。这是关于一种肉，也许是美国最卑微、最令人难堪的肉，是否能在地球上的某个地方，浸入深炸锅这种伟大的烹饪平衡器的红色洗礼油中。它可能会脱胎换骨，不再是个被放逐者，而是梳洗干净，穿着西装打着领带。它可能会重获新生出现在餐桌上。
Through sheer force of resemblance, it might be loved, its history, years of drudgery and hardship, doing the body's least glamorous job, all washed away. No, this is not the story of a con man like Bernie Madoff. It's Pretty Woman. This is whether Good Will Hunting finds his way out of Southie. It's whether Charlie, on that very last chocolate bar, really can get a golden ticket.
凭借相似的力量，它可能会被喜爱，它的历史，那些年的苦役和艰辛，做着身体最不光彩的工作，全都一洗而空。不，这不是伯尼·麦道夫那样的骗子故事。这是《漂亮女人》。这是关于《心灵捕手》中的查理是否能找到走出南波士顿的路。这是关于查理在最后那块巧克力里是否真的能得到金奖券。
To do all this, to try it, I called my little sister, Lauren. She's a chef, trained abroad at The Cordon Bleu, worked at Michelin-star restaurants. She's that kind of chef. Soon, we were standing in front of a deli case. And I don't know why I feel hesitant about saying this because I don't think it's racist. It was in Chinatown.
为了做这一切，为了尝试，我打电话给我的小妹妹劳伦。她是一位厨师，在蓝带学院进修过，在米其林星级餐厅工作过。她是那种水平的厨师。很快，我们就站在一个熟食柜前。我不知道为什么我提到这一点时感到犹豫，因为我不认为这是种族主义。那是在唐人街。
Pork bung, there it is. Look at it, it looks like a sphincter.
猪直肠，就在那儿。看看它，它看起来像括约肌。
Wait, what do you mean, it looks like a--
等等，你是指它看起来像个——
This one up here, that's cut up, it looks like a butt hole.
上面这个，切开的，看起来像个屁眼。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
It does.
的确。
And Lauren had theories about pulling it off-- brining, soaking, maybe braising. But once we got to the store, once she'd seen the meat up close, her doubts got worse.
劳伦对如何做到这一点有理论——盐渍、浸泡，也许是炖煮。但一旦我们到了商店，一旦她近距离看到这些肉，她的疑虑就加深了。
I think, after looking at it, I don't think it's going to--
我想，看过之后，我不觉得它会——
You don't think it's going to work?
你不觉得它会成功？
No. It's too thick. There's too much muscle tissue. It's too thick. You'd have to use a ring cutter to make it the right thickness.
不。它太厚了。肌肉组织太多。它太厚了。你得用圆环切割机把它切成合适的厚度。
What do you think those bits are, in there?
你觉得里面的那些碎块是什么？
Oh, you know, poo.
噢，你知道，屎。
My sister said Eddie Lin was definitely right. The giveaway would be the stubborn flavor of poo. That flavor, she said, it's tough to get rid of. The Earth revolves around the sun. And bung will always taste like [BLEEP].
我妹妹说埃迪·林绝对是对的。败笔就是那种挥之不去的屎味。她说，那种味道很难去掉。地球绕着太阳转。而直肠永远尝起来像（哔）。
But there was no backing out now. We would eat. We would eat our way to the truth. And so what if it didn't look good? So what if bung was destined to taste like bung? You know who it didn't look good for, and he still put up a fight? Rocky Balboa, that's who. This was it, the bung versus calamari, squid versus tail, The Rumble in the Bunghole.
但现在没有退路了。我们会吃。我们要通过吃来找到真相。如果它看起来不好看又怎样？如果直肠注定要尝起来像直肠又怎样？你知道谁看起来情况不好，却依然抗争吗？洛奇·巴尔博亚，就是他。这就是了，直肠对阵鱿鱼，鱿鱼对阵尾巴，直肠里的隆隆声。
We set up the tasting at a restaurant, in the lull between lunch and dinner. In the dining room, there was just a few tables eating. And all around the restaurant, the morning shift was wrapping up as we walked in with a red cooler filled with squid and hog bung.
我们在午餐和晚餐之间的空档期设置了品尝环节。餐厅里只有几桌客人在用餐。当我们拎着装满鱿鱼和猪直肠的红色冷藏箱走进来时，整个餐厅的早班工作人员正在收尾。
So originally, I'd recruited some half a dozen people from our office at This American Life as tasters. The final group the day of the tasting included, from the office, Seth Lind and Brian Reed.
最初，我从我们的《美国生活》办公室里招募了大约半打人作为评委。品尝当天的最终小组成员包括办公室的塞斯·林德和布莱恩·里德。
So when's the last time that you guys had calamari?
你们上次吃鱿鱼是什么时候？
I had calamari probably a month ago.
我大概一个月前吃了鱿鱼。
And what about you, Brian?
那你呢，布莱恩？
I haven't had it since we got this tip about the possible--
自从我们得到这个可能的线索后，我就没吃过——
Oh, my gosh, have you been avoiding?
噢，天呐，你一直在避开它吗？
Yeah, no, totally. And to be honest, I ate calamari pretty regular. I'm a regular eater of calamari-- not all the time, but it's something I'll routinely order if it's on an appetizer menu.
是的，完全避开了。老实说，我以前经常吃鱿鱼。我是鱿鱼的常客——不是一直吃，但如果开胃菜菜单上有它，我会习惯性地点。
Yeah.
对。
I mean, I grew up in an Italian-American family, where my grandparents were also born here. I feel like calamari is just big among that sector of people, at Olive Garden and stuff like that. So I just grew up eating it.
我是说，我在一个意大利裔美国人家庭长大，我的祖父母也是在这里出生的。我觉得鱿鱼在这些人中间很受欢迎，比如在橄榄花园餐厅之类的。所以我从小就吃它。
I hadn't realized this. For weeks, Brian had been avoiding calamari. He'd been living in fear.
我没意识到这一点。几个星期以来，布莱恩一直在避开鱿鱼。他一直生活在恐惧中。
Brian, if you find out that they're indiscernible from each other, will you ever eat calamari again?
布莱恩，如果你发现它们无法区分，你还会再吃鱿鱼吗？
No, I don't think so. That's why I want to do this, just to know, going forward.
不，我不觉得。这就是我想做这个的原因，就是为了知道未来的情况。
Back in the kitchen, things were looking bad. I'd given up on the idea that bung would taste the same as calamari. Now I'd hung my hopes on the idea that at least visually, it would look the same. But as my sister dropped the flowered rings of hog bung into the fryer, they had turned into this kind of big, ugly, tangled wad, nothing like the jiggly squid rings.
回到厨房，情况看起来很不妙。我已经放弃了直肠尝起来和鱿鱼一样的念头。现在我寄希望于它至少在视觉上看起来是一样的。但当我的妹妹把裹了面糊的猪直肠圈放进油锅里时，它们变成了一种巨大的、丑陋的、纠结的一团，一点也不像那些有弹性的鱿鱼圈。
Oh, they're very scraggly-looking.
噢，它们看起来非常破烂。
But then, as if by a miracle, they changed. My sister gave a shake to the fry basket, and as they sizzled, the bung just seemed to gracefully snap into rings.
但接着，仿佛奇迹发生，它们变了。我妹妹摇了摇炸篮，随着它们滋滋作响，直肠似乎优雅地弹成了圆圈。
Oh, look at that, though. It's like magic. They're turning into circles.
噢，看那个，太棒了。就像魔法。它们正在变成圆圈。
Yeah. So I'm going to pull these first ones.
是啊。所以我先把这第一批捞出来。
Soon, we were face to face with the plate. On it, there were two piles of rings, similar in size, similar in shape. The bung had more of a frizzly edge to it, kind of like a fancy onion ring. The calamari was smoother.
很快，我们面对着盘子。上面有两堆圈，大小相似，形状相似。直肠的边缘更多毛，有点像高档的洋葱圈。鱿鱼的更光滑。
OK, so--
好的，那么——
I asked Seth and Brian to just give a first impression.
我让塞斯和布莱恩先谈谈第一印象。
I have a guess. But it's one of those things where you're pretty sure, but you could totally be wrong.
我有猜想。但这是那种你很确定，但却完全可能弄错的情况。
God, I thought I would be more sure. I don't-- I'm waffling now. My gut reaction is that this was calamari and this was not.
天呐，我以为我会更确定。我不知道……我现在很犹豫。我的直觉反应是，这个是鱿鱼，这个不是。
OK, before you eat it, see, I totally thought this was calamari, the other one.
好的，在你吃之前，看，我完全以为这一堆是鱿鱼。
OK.
好的。
So I'm going to do it at the same time.
所以我打算同时吃。
OK, so just to be clear what's going on here, Seth has chosen one pile of rings which he thinks is calamari. Brian has done the same thing, only Brian is choosing the other stack of fried rings.
好的，为了澄清一下这里发生了什么，塞斯挑选了一堆他认为是鱿鱼的圈。布莱恩也做了同样的事，只是他选的是另一堆炸圈。
OK, so we're about to bite into these simultaneously, which we both think this is calamari.
好的，我们要同时咬下去，我们都认为这是鱿鱼。
But they're the opposite ones.
但它们是相反的。
The opposite ones. OK.
相反的。好的。
[CRUNCHING]
（咀嚼声）
So in actuality, Seth is right. Seth is eating calamari. The chewing you hear from Brian's mic, that is the sound of a calamari lover eating fried pig rectum. I should also add there were actually two varieties of bung on the plate that day, one bung that my sister had blanched over and over to mellow any organ-y, fecal flavor, and then untreated, straight-up bung, unfiltered, unchained, uncut, 100% pure bung. That one, the latter one, bung at its purest, at the height of its bunginess, this is what Brian was eating. As they ate, Seth still looked confident.
所以事实上，塞斯对了。塞斯吃的是鱿鱼。你从布莱恩麦克风里听到的咀嚼声，是一个鱿鱼爱好者在吃炸猪直肠的声音。我还要补充一点，那天盘子里实际上有两种直肠，一种是我妹妹反复焯水以减轻任何器官腥味、粪便味处理过的，另一种是未处理的、直截了当的直肠，未过滤、未受限、未切割，100%纯直肠。后者，那种最纯粹的、直肠味最浓的，就是布莱恩在吃的。当他们吃的时候，塞斯看起来依然很自信。
I think I was right.
我想我对了。
(LAUGHING) I think I was right.
（笑）我想我对了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I totally think I was right.
是的。我完全认为我对了。
Game, set, match, bung. And it wasn't just Brian. I thought so. Damien, who manages the restaurant, he also thought it was passable. A few of us picked up a faint flavor of pork rind, but if you weren't really looking for it, you wouldn't notice it was there. One of the restaurant staff, a guy named Ethan Vanburen, had the simplest, clearest explanation.
局、盘、赛，直肠赢。不仅仅是布莱恩。我也这么认为。餐厅经理达米恩也认为这可以蒙混过关。我们中有几个人闻到了淡淡的猪油味，但如果你不是真的在找，你不会注意到它在那里。餐厅员工之一伊桑·范布伦，给出了最简单、最清晰的解释。
I think that when you slice something up really thin and deep fry it, it's going to taste like something that's been deep fried.
我觉得当你把东西切得很薄然后深度油炸时，它就会尝起来像某种油炸的东西。
If a plate full of the bung came out, how many people do you think would even-- do you think you'd notice if you were in that setting?
如果端上来一盘直肠，你觉得有多少人会注意到？你觉得你在那种环境下会注意到吗？
I'd say top scenario is somebody says, this calamari tastes funny, and keeps eating it.
我会说最糟糕的情况就是有人说，“这鱿鱼吃起来怪怪的”，然后继续吃。
And as for Brian-- oh, Brian-- Brian was reeling a bit, trying to figure out just what this was going to mean for him.
至于布莱恩——噢，布莱恩——他有点晕头转向，试图弄清楚这对意味着什么。
I'm sure I've been fooled in the past. I'm just, like, sure of it.
我肯定以前被骗过。我只是……就是确定。
Wait, oh, you're thinking that you've been places in the past, and you've had bung?
等等，你是说你觉得你以前去过某些地方，吃过直肠？
I just imagined seeing a plate with this food, that looks like this on it, sitting with my family, growing up. We definitely have eaten something that tasted like this, and just thought it was calamari, for sure.
我只是想象着看到一盘这样的食物，长成这样，坐在家里和家人一起吃。我们绝对吃过这种味道的东西，而且肯定以为是鱿鱼。
Not only wasn't he sure if he'd ever eat calamari again, he didn't want to eat the calamari on the plate in front of him, calamari I guaranteed him, was real.
他不仅不确定是否还会再吃鱿鱼，甚至不想吃盘子里面前的鱿鱼，我保证，那是真的鱿鱼。
Just to repeat one last time, I have no proof that anyone, anywhere, has ever tried to pass off pork bung as calamari in a restaurant. All I know is, if you wanted to do it, it would be easy. And I'm choosing to believe that it's happening somewhere, because at some point in working on this story, I stopped identifying with Brian and anyone who might feel ripped off or grossed out by getting imitation instead of the real thing.
最后重复一遍，我没有任何证据表明有人、在任何地方，曾试图在餐馆里把猪直肠当作鱿鱼来卖。我只知道，如果你想这样做，这很容易。我选择相信它在某处正在发生，因为在制作这个故事的过程中，我不禁认同了布莱恩和任何因为吃到了替代品而非真品而感到被坑或恶心的人。
Now, I identify with the bung. I'd like to think that somewhere out there, right now, under a heat lamp, a platter is sitting. It's warm, and it's full of promise and transformation and redemption. That's the world that I'll choose to live in for me, for you, for the bung. For the bung in all of us.
现在，我认同了直肠。我愿意相信，在某处的加热灯下，正摆着一个盘子。它是温暖的，充满了希望、改变和救赎。那是我选择去生活的世界，为了我，为了你，为了直肠。为了我们每个人身体里的直肠。
Ben Calhoun, he's one of the producers of our program.
本·卡尔霍恩，他是我们节目的制作人之一。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Ben Calhoun, he's one of the producers of our program. Thanks to the restaurant Aurora, in Brooklyn, for letting us use their kitchen for our taste test.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）本·卡尔霍恩，他是我们节目的制作人之一。感谢布鲁克林的Aurora餐厅让我们使用他们的厨房进行品尝测试。
OK.
好的。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) OK, who is this? Wait, who am I?
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）好的，这是谁？等等，我是谁？
Well, coming up, Philadelphia and Afghanistan, doppelgangers?
嗯，即将到来，费城和阿富汗，分身？
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）那是一分钟之后。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) So we're going to start act 2?
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）所以我们要开始第二幕了？
Start here. So we're coming back from the ID break.
从这开始。我们刚从身份识别停顿中回来。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme. We bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, doppelgangers, stories of things that have a double, an evil twin, or a not-so-evil twin.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题。我们带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，分身，关于那些有双重身份、邪恶双胞胎或并非那么邪恶的双胞胎的故事。
Oh, wait, I should just explain. Oh, right, so--
噢，等等，我应该解释一下。噢，对了，所以——
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) What?
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）什么？
That was just a note to myself. I should explain.
那只是给自己的笔记。我应该解释。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) No, that was a note to me.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）不，那是给我的笔记。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
So this is why Fred is here. Fred Armisen is co-hosting the show as me because it's a show about doubles and lookalikes.
所以这就是为什么弗雷德在这里。弗雷德·阿米森作为我来共同主持节目，因为这是一个关于双胞胎和长相相似者的节目。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Right, but we're both creating the same person, in a sense. And that's what the fun is of--
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）对，但我们都在创造同一个人，某种意义上。这就是乐趣所在——
Oh, that was really good, the way you just did that.
噢，这真的很好，你刚才那样做的方式。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
Finish your thought.
说完你的想法。
I didn't have an end to that thought. I just--
我没有结束那个想法。我只是——
You just knew that--
你只是知道——
I like when you do the little self-- the little discovery.
我喜欢你做那个小自我发现的时候。
All right, well, we have arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, In Country and City. So for decades now, the writer Alex Kotlowitz has been writing about the inner cities, and especially the toll of violence on young people. He's probably best known for his book, There Are No Children Here. He appears on our show from time to time.
好的，我们已经到达了节目的第二幕，第二幕，在乡村和城市。几十年来，作家亚历克斯·科特洛维茨一直在描写内城，特别是暴力对年轻人的代价。他可能最出名的是他的书《这里没有孩子》。他偶尔出现在我们的节目中。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Recently, he heard about an unusual program at Drexel University in Philadelphia, where they're giving guys from inner city neighborhoods counseling for symptoms of PTSD.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）最近，他听说费城德雷塞尔大学有一个不寻常的项目，他们为来自内城社区的人们提供PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）症状的咨询。
And this interested Alex, because for a long time, he has wondered whether the violence that he was reporting on in Chicago and its effect on kids and adults was comparable to the effects of trauma that a person experiences at war.
这引起了亚历克斯的兴趣，因为很长一段时间以来，他一直在想，他所报道的芝加哥暴力事件及其对儿童和成人的影响，是否与一个人在战争中经历的创伤影响具有可比性。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) So he knew, and we know, how strange that sounds, to compare being in Afghanistan or Iraq to working a street corner in Chicago or some other city.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）所以他知道，我们也知道，把在阿富汗或伊拉克与在芝加哥或其他城市街头工作相提并论，听起来是多么奇怪。
So Alex tried to see if it was really comparable by doing a pair of interviews. He talked to this vet from Afghanistan and also a guy from Philadelphia, who's lived in some pretty bad neighborhoods his whole life. Alex wanted to see if they were doubles of some kind for each other.
所以亚历克斯试图通过进行一对访谈来看看这是否真的具有可比性。他采访了这位从阿富汗回来的老兵，还有一位来自费城、一生都住在相当糟糕社区的家伙。亚历克斯想看看他们是否是彼此的某种分身。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) One of these guys is 28, one is 30, and both of them are trying to make sense of what they experienced. Here's Alex.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）这些人中一个是28岁，一个是30岁，他们都在试图理解自己经历过的事情。这是亚历克斯。
Here's the first of these two guys, Brandon Caro. Brandon spent a year in Afghanistan. His roughest time was the six months he spent in the eastern part of the country, near the Pakistani border. He was a Navy corpsman, a medic who worked with the Marines.
这是两人中的第一位，布兰登·卡罗。布兰登在阿富汗待了一年。他最艰难的时期是在该国东部，靠近巴基斯坦边境的地方待的那六个月。他是海军医务兵，是与海军陆战队一起工作的军医。
As a teenager, yeah, I certainly lacked discipline. I had been thrown out of my house more times than I can remember. And I was 21 when I enlisted. And really, I enlisted because I had, up to that point, not finished college. And it didn't seem as though I was going to finish college any time soon.
作为一个少年，是的，我肯定缺乏纪律。我被赶出家的次数多到数不清。我21岁时应征入伍。真的，我参军是因为到那时为止，我没完成大学学业。看起来我也不会在短期内完成大学学业。
Then there's Curtis Jefferson. He grew up in a rough neighborhood in North Philly, where he oversaw a small group of guys who sold drugs. He made his first drug sale when he was still in high school.
然后是柯蒂斯·杰斐逊。他在北费城一个糟糕的社区长大，在那里他监督了一小群贩毒的人。他还在上高中时就进行了第一次毒品交易。
I was 16. My aunt gave me some money for school. And that point, I purchased some weed and some crack with that, never bought my clothes. After that, I sold all the drugs. And I guess from there, that's where it started. I seen that money come in, and I wasn't asking nobody for no money. Especially with my aunt, I wasn't begging for from her pockets and all that. So from there, it was all she wrote.
我16岁。姑姑给了我一些零花钱。在那一点上，我买了些大麻和快克毒品，从来没买过衣服。从那以后，我卖了所有的毒品。我猜从那时起，一切开始了。我看到钱进来，我不向任何人要钱。特别是对我姑姑，我没求过她的钱。所以从那时起，一切就注定了。
OK, they're two completely different people who made very different choices in their lives. But I spoke to each of them, looking for similarities in their experiences. And honestly, there were more than I expected. Here's the first similarity.
好吧，他们是两个完全不同的人，在生活中做了非常不同的选择。但我与他们每个人都进行了交谈，寻找他们经历中的相似之处。老实说，相似之处比我预期的要多。这是第一个相似之处。
For Curtis on the street, and for Brandon in Afghanistan, they could never let their guard down. During his tour, Brandon was charged with training Afghan soldiers. And in May 2007, he heard about Afghan soldiers who attacked their American trainers.
对于街头的柯蒂斯和在阿富汗的布兰登来说，他们永远不能放松警惕。在服役期间，布兰登负责训练阿富汗士兵。2007年5月，他听说阿富汗士兵袭击了他们的美国教官。
They had weapons around us all the time. On convoys, we would have to line him up in the morning and collect their cell phones because we couldn't trust them not to inform on us to Taliban fighters. It was exhausting, trying to keep an eye on the Afghan soldiers and look out for IEDs or snipers.
他们身边一直有武器。在车队里，我们每天早上都得让他们排队收集他们的手机，因为我们不敢相信他们不会向塔利班武装人员通风报信。这让人筋疲力尽，试图盯着阿富汗士兵，还要提防路边炸弹或狙击手。
Because you're trying to focus on one thing, you're trying to get money, but the same thing, eventually, somebody's going to come up and test you. Somebody's going to test you. Somebody's going to rob you. Somebody's going to send something to your boys, they're going to get robbed. Somebody's going to send shots your way or something.
因为你试图专注于一件事，你试图赚钱，但同样的事情，最终，有人会来测试你。有人会测试你。有人会抢劫你。有人会给你的弟兄发点什么，他们会被抢劫。有人会向你开枪或者什么的。
It felt like a piano could fall on you at any time. That's what it felt like to be on patrol, and especially to be on patrol with the Afghans.
感觉像钢琴随时会掉在你身上。在巡逻时，特别是在和阿富汗人一起巡逻时，感觉就是这样。
Because when you're out there, you notice different things-- for one, people with their hands in their pockets.
因为当你出去时，你会注意到不同的事情——首先，人们把手放在口袋里。
You're looking for someone that doesn't look right, that doesn't feel right.
你在寻找看起来不对劲、感觉不对劲的人。
Another thing, people who've got hoodies on, especially black. There's a certain look, put the hoodie on their face, you can't even see their eyeballs. Come on, it's daytime. I can't see your face. Let me see your eyes or something.
另外，戴着连帽衫的人，特别是黑色的。有一种样子，连帽衫戴在脸上，你甚至看不见他们的眼球。得了吧，这是白天。我看不到你的脸。让我看看你的眼睛或者什么的。
And I would watch the way they looked at me, If they would stare back at me, if they would smile at me.
我会观察他们看我的方式，如果他们盯着我，如果他们对我微笑。
If a person always got to keep touching their side, you're not going in your pocket, you're touching something. And I've been out there so long, I could tell if somebody's got a gun on them or not.
如果一个人总是摸自己的腰，你不是在掏口袋，你是在摸什么东西。我在外面待得太久了，我能看出某人身上有没有枪。
For some reason, it was always a white Toyota Camry that was packed with explosives and driven into a convoy, or driven into a checkpoint.
由于某种原因，总是一辆塞满炸药的白色丰田凯美瑞被开进车队，或开进检查站。
Grand Marquis, or what else? Crown Victoria, that's a dope-boy car. When I seen them cars when I was on the streets, it was either get ready, go for the straps, go to the guns, or get out of the way. That might be the hop-out boys, come stick you up.
水星大侯爵，或者还有什么？皇冠维多利亚，那是毒贩的车。当我还在街上看到这些车时，要么做好准备，要么去拿带子，去拿枪，或者躲开。那可能是“跳车帮”，来抢劫你的。
Here's something else they shared. They both saw people killed, and then had to figure out how to keep going. The first fatality Brandon ever saw came when a convoy, which he was originally scheduled to be a part of, was hit.
这是他们共有的另一件事。他们都目睹过人被杀，然后必须想办法继续生活。布兰登目睹的第一次死亡事件发生在原定他也要参加的一个车队遭到袭击时。
They brought the casualties into our base. And when we swung open the two doors that opened up into the cab of the truck, I was looking at just a heap, a mass of flesh, and that gray, digital-pattern Army uniform. But there was no form to what I was looking at. I knew that what I was looking at was human. But I didn't know what position the body was in because it had been so badly damaged.
他们把伤员送到了我们的基地。当我们推开卡车驾驶室的两扇门时，我看到的只是一堆血肉，还有那灰色的、数码迷彩的陆军制服。但我看的东西没有形状。我知道我看到的是人。但我不知道身体处于什么位置，因为它受损太严重了。
And so we got into the cab and we started to put him into a bag. And I tried not to look at his face. I remember thinking, don't look at his face, don't look at his face. But I had to, inevitably. It was by far, the most intimate, goriest thing I've ever experienced in my life.
于是我们进了驾驶室，开始把他放进袋子里。我尽量不看他的脸。我记得心里想，别看他的脸，别看他的脸。但我不得不看，不可避免。这绝对是我一生中经历过的最私密、最血腥的事情。
My first time seeing somebody shot was my own mother. I was five years old, going on six. We were living in the projects, Blumberg projects. My mom, she just got her degree in nursing. She was a nurse, had a nice little job. She was working to get us out of the projects.
我第一次看到有人被枪杀是我自己的母亲。我当时5岁，快6岁了。我们住在布伦伯格公屋项目。我妈刚拿到护理学位。她是个护士，有一份不错的工作。她正在努力让我们搬出公屋。
Then one morning, she was going out to work, gave my mom a kiss on the lips, and she told my grandma, I'll see y'all later. I'm going to work. As soon as she went out to work, I just heard all this shooting. By that time, I knew what shooting was. But there it was. She just got caught up in a shootout.
然后一天早上，她要去上班，亲了亲我的唇，告诉祖母，我会晚点见你们。我要去上班了。她刚一出门，我就听到所有的枪声。那时候，我知道什么是枪声。但它就在那里。她只是被卷入了一场枪战。
Somebody knocked on the door. She told my grandma, she said, Barbara's laying on the ground. All I know is my grandma was screaming and hollering. And she ran outside. And there she was, right on the ground, just red blood, just nothing but blood.
有人敲门。她告诉祖母，她说，芭芭拉倒在地上。我只知道祖母在大叫大嚷。她跑了出去。她就在那里，就在地上，只有红色的血，除了血什么都没有。
Just looking at it her, I'm five years old, like, what's wrong with Mommy, Grandma? What's wrong with her? My grandma's crying and screaming. She didn't even say nothing. She just keep telling me, go in the house, go in the house, go in the house.
看着她，我当时5岁，像是，妈妈怎么了，祖母？她怎么了？祖母在哭喊。她甚至没说什么。她只是不停地告诉我，进屋去，进屋去，进屋去。
I was angry a lot, every day, every day, because I thought about my mom, every day, every day, every day. I still think about her every day.
我每天都很生气，每天，因为我每天、每天、每天都想到我妈妈。我仍然每天想她。
From that point on, it was very difficult for me to sleep, to focus. I didn't realize how much those things really had made an impact on me, but they did.
从那时起，我很难睡觉、集中精力。我没意识到这些事情对我产生了多大的影响，但确实有。
I seen a lot of people get shot. I seen people get shot by cops. And I seen best friends shoot each other. I seen all types of crazy stuff. I don't know.
我看到很多人被枪杀。我看到人被警察枪杀。我看到最好的朋友互相射击。我看到了各种疯狂的事情。我不知道。
There was a convoy that went up to Naray, in which there was a sniper attack that killed my old sergeant and his sergeant. There was the rocket-propelled grenade attack on a tent, inside our FOB, followed up by machine-gun fire.
有一个车队去了纳雷，那里发生了狙击袭击，打死了我的老士官和他的士官。前沿作战基地内发生了一起针对帐篷的火箭助推榴弹袭击，随后是机枪扫射。
[SIGHS] I could say I had seen a dozen. And for me to not even be like no cop or no doctor or nothing, that's a whole lot to see somebody killed and dead. That's a whole lot.
（叹气）我可以说我见过一打。对我来说，哪怕不是警察或医生，看到有人被杀、死亡，那也是非常多的。那真的非常多。
This brings us to the third parallel, they buried their feelings.
这就引出了第三个平行点，他们埋葬了自己的感情。
Well, after my mom got shot, I didn't get no counseling. I didn't get no counselor at all. And my aunt asked me, too. My aunt gave me a decision. And she asked me one day. I had to have been, like, 12. She was like, do you want to go to counseling? And I told her, no, for what? I don't need to talk to nobody. I was so much in denial. I think I can handle everything by myself, but I really couldn't.
嗯，我妈妈被枪杀后，我没得到任何咨询。我根本没找过咨询师。我姑姑也问过我。我姑姑给了我一个决定。有一天她问我。我当时一定有12岁了。她说，你想去咨询吗？我告诉她，不，为了什么？我不想跟任何人说话。我当时太否认了。我想我可以独自处理一切，但我真的不行。
I think at that point, I was probably still in denial. I knew that I was toting around a lot of emotional baggage. As much as I wanted to talk to people about how I really felt, I also didn't want to talk about it at all. The more I'd give it air, the more real it would be. And I didn't want it to be real. I just wanted it to be over.
我觉得在那一点上，我可能还在否认。我知道我背负着很多情感包袱。尽管我想跟人谈论我的真实感受，但我根本不想谈论它。我越让它透气，它就越真实。而我不希望它真实。我只想让它结束。
I can't show no weakness because, you know what I mean? My homies need me out there. And I've been doing that for years. It's to the point, I started getting adapted to it, like, [BLEEP]. But at the same time, I was still scared. Don't nobody want to die like that.
我不能表现出任何软弱，因为，你懂我的意思吗？我的兄弟们需要我在外面。我这样做很多年了。到了这种程度，我已经开始适应它了，比如，（哔）。但与此同时，我仍然害怕。没人想那样死。
The fourth shared experience-- raw, unfiltered rage.
第四个共同经历——原始的、未经过滤的愤怒。
I was definitely looking for revenge for my mom. When I was about 10 years old, I told my aunt I was going to look for the people that killed my mom. And I was going to go back down to the projects, and I was going to kill them. I always thought like that.
我绝对在为我妈妈报仇。我大约10岁的时候，告诉姑姑我要找杀害我妈妈的人。我要回公屋去，我要杀了他们。我总是那么想。
I mean, the way I felt about the Afghans, I began to just hate that whole culture, entirely. I hated them. There was one time, we were driving on an extremely, extremely dangerous road. And we had come very close to falling off the cliff, which would have killed us.
我是说，我对阿富汗人的感觉，我开始憎恨整个文化。我恨他们。有一次，我们在一条极其危险的路上开车。我们差点从悬崖上掉下去，那会杀了我们。
And the truck to our front was a truck filled with Afghan soldiers. And they were pointing and laughing at us for almost falling off. And in that moment, more than any other moment, I wanted to open up on them and kill every one of them. I've realized how much anger and resentment I have, and how dangerous that is.
我们前面的卡车是一辆装满阿富汗士兵的卡车。他们指着我们笑，因为我们差点掉下去。那一刻，比任何其他时刻，我都想开火，杀死他们每一个人。我意识到我有多少愤怒和怨恨，那是多么危险。
Man, I shot my sister's boyfriend. I mean, he-- I don't know, I think I had one of them moments. It had to have been, because it just took one word, and it just set me off for no reason, just thinking about everything. And I just shot him.
伙计，我枪击了我姐姐的男朋友。我是说，他……我不知道，我想我当时脑子抽了。一定是的，因为只用了一个词，没有任何理由就让我爆发了，我想到了一切。然后我就开枪打了他。
I felt some type of way. I made the situation deeper, and it wasn't. You know what I mean? It wasn't even that deep. But I've been holding a lot of stuff in, because he was always trying to discipline me. That's what it was, I didn't like about it, how he always tried to discipline me.
我感觉到了某种方式。我让情况变得更严重了，其实不然。你懂我意思吗？那甚至没那么严重。但我一直憋着很多东西，因为他总是试图管教我。就是那样，我不喜欢它，他总是试图管教我。
All my sisters are way older than me, they're 40, pushing 50. See what I'm saying? I'm the youngest. And I'm the only boy. So her boyfriends, they're just, oh, you need to stop getting the streets. But it's just how he was saying it. Don't raise your voice at me. He's talking about, yeah, I'm going to take you in the street and fight you and all this. You're going to learn your lesson.
我所有的姐姐都比我大得多，她们40岁，快50了。明白我说的吗？我是家里最小的。我是唯一的男孩。所以她的男朋友们，他们只是，噢，你得停止混街头了。但这只是他说的方式。别对我大声喊叫。他在说，是啊，我要带你到街上跟你打架，还有所有这一切。你会得到教训的。
It just was the part where he was like, yeah, I'm going to knock you the [BLEEP] out. And that just went in my head, like, what? First thing I do is grab my gun and come around the corner. And he was outside, too. And I'm thinking the whole time, I hope he ain't really outside. So he thinks I'm going to fight him. I'm not fighting this man. I'm going to kill him.
只是在他那样说的那一部分，是啊，我要把你这（哔）家伙打趴下。那句话就钻进我脑子里，像是，什么？我做的第一件事就是抓起我的枪，走到拐角处。他也在外面。我一直在想，我希望他不是真的在外面。所以他以为我要去跟他打架。我才不跟他打。我要杀了他。
I didn't even give him a chance to put his hands up. As soon as I got around there, he was just all in my face, and just backed up and shot him, shot him in the stomach. I thought I was going to kill him. I thought he was dead, though. I guess everything worked out in its ways. He's ain't a person to tell-- he ain't tell. He still survived, so I don't know.
我甚至没给他举手的机会。我一过去，他就在我脸上，我就后退并开枪打中了他的肚子。我以为我要杀了他。我以为他死了，真的。我猜一切都按各自的方式发展了。他不是那种会告诉……他没告发。他还活着，所以我不知道。
Here's something I didn't expect with either of them. The toughest times weren't when they were on the battlefield or in the streets. It was when things were quiet. That's when they struggled the most.
这是我没料到他们两人会有的情况。最艰难的时候不是他们在战场上或街头时。而是安静的时候。那是他们最挣扎的时候。
The worst times, for me, were the times where we weren't out on patrol, because that's when I was alone with my thoughts. And I would try to clear my head. It was impossible. These thoughts would just appear. I would worry. I thought about what it would be like to be shot.
对我来说，最糟糕的时候是我们没有巡逻的时候，因为那时我独自面对自己的思绪。我会试图理清头绪。这不可能。这些念头就会出现。我会担心。我想象着被枪杀会是什么感觉。
I might daydream, just look at my ceiling or something, watch TV, like, damn, just imagine bullets going, ripping through my body. You know, mother-[BLEEP] just come out with a gun, just start shooting everything. And I'm getting hit. Everybody getting hit.
我可能会做白日梦，盯着天花板或者什么的，看电视，比如，该死，想象着子弹穿过我的身体。你知道，那个混蛋拿着枪出来，开始扫射一切。然后我中弹了。每个人都中弹了。
I would think what it would feel like to be blown up in an IED, to be pinned down, and have the vehicle set ablaze, and to burn alive, to be trapped in the truck because the doors were too heavy to cut through or to pull open.
我会想被路边炸弹炸死、被困住、车辆着火、活活烧死是什么感觉，因为车门太重无法切开或拉开而困在卡车里。
Seeing it like this, seeing it with my own eyes, just look, seeing blood, and me just falling to the ground, and is too late for the ambulance? Would I still be alive when the ambulance come get me? Or that crazy kind of stuff, like, when you sit and think about that stuff, that kind of stuff drives you crazy.
亲眼看到它，用自己的眼睛看，就是看，看着血，我倒在地上，救护车来不及了吗？救护车来时我还会活着吗？或者那种疯狂的事情，比如，当你坐下来思考那些事情时，那种事情会让你发疯。
For both, reality eventually caught up to their fears. In the spring of 2006, Curtis told us he got caught in a shootout with rival drug dealers. The first bullet, to his back, spun him around. He got hit four more times, in the stomach and in the arm. As a result, he walks doubled over, like an old man. Because a permanent nerve damage, he falls a lot. And when he's under stress or eats the wrong food, he has bleeding from his intestines.
对两人来说，现实最终追上了他们的恐惧。2006年春天，柯蒂斯告诉我们，他卷入了一场与敌对毒贩的枪战。第一颗子弹击中他的后背，让他转了身。他又中弹四次，在胃部和手臂。结果，他弯着腰走路，像个老人。因为永久的神经损伤，他经常摔倒。当他有压力或吃了错误的食物时，他的肠道会出血。
Brandon, too, was hurt in a rollover when his Humvee fell off a small cliff. Brandon had been manning the turret, and fortunately, another soldier pulled him in just as the vehicle rolled. He suffered three fractures of his vertebrae and two herniated disks, and the pain kept him up nights, even after he left Afghanistan.
布兰登在悍马车从悬崖坠落时也受了伤。布兰登当时在炮塔操纵位置，幸运的是，车辆翻滚时另一名士兵把他拉了进来。他的椎骨发生三处骨折，两处椎间盘突出，疼痛让他即使在离开阿富汗后也彻夜难眠。
Both men were on a lot of medications after their injuries. And our sixth similarity may not be so surprising-- they self-medicated.
两人受伤后都服用了很多药物，我们的第六个相似之处可能并不令人惊讶——他们自我药疗。
I had started to drink again. And on the weekends, I would drink heavily.
我开始重新喝酒。周末，我会大量饮酒。
It makes my body just feel a little better, like just a little basic, Mary Jane, that's all.
这让我的身体感觉好一点，就像一些基础的“玛丽·简”（大麻），就是这样。
Usually a Crown and Coke was my drink of choice. And I would probably drink at least 5, up to 8, 9, 10 in the night.
通常“皇冠和可乐”是我选择的饮料。我晚上可能会喝至少5杯，多达8、9、10杯。
But sometimes, it do give me the opposite effect.
但有时，它确实会产生相反的效果。
When I was very, very drunk, I would start to cry because of how upset I was.
当我喝得非常非常醉时，我会因为自己有多难过而开始哭。
Because, you know, when I smoke, it put me on a mellow. Then, you know, you just start thinking. Then that's when all the thoughts just come, like, oh, what the hell they just come from? And I'd be like, oh, some thoughts I think sometimes, I don't want to think about.
因为，你知道，当我抽烟时，它会让我进入一种平和的状态。然后，你知道，你开始思考。然后这就是所有思绪涌现的时候，比如，噢，它们到底从哪里来的？我会像，噢，有些念头我想的时候，我不想去想。
Echo number seven, they lashed out at friends and family. Curtis had night terrors, and would wake in the middle of the night thinking his girlfriend was someone who was trying to shoot him. He'd push her. He'd hit her in the head. He'd call her names.
第七个共鸣，他们对朋友和家人发火。柯蒂斯有夜惊，他会半夜醒来，以为他的女朋友是试图枪杀他的人。他会推她。他会打她的头。他会骂她。
I just was like, dang, I know I'm hurting this girl. I'm really putting my hands on her, like a man, putting marks on her arms. And I said, I'm losing it. And I was like, shh.
我只是像，该死，我知道我在伤害这个女孩。我真的像个男人一样对她动手，在她的手臂上留下痕迹。我说，我正在失去理智。我就像，嘘。
Brandon had a difficult relationship with a girlfriend, too. They'd get into huge arguments and she'd get scared. One time, Brandon got so agitated, a friend intervened and tried to calm him down. Brandon punched him. His girlfriend locked herself in her room and called the police.
布兰登和女朋友的关系也很艰难。他们会发生巨大的争吵，她会感到害怕。有一次，布兰登变得如此焦躁，一个朋友介入并试图让他平静下来。布兰登打了他。他的女朋友把自己锁在房间里报了警。
Police came. And I was inside. And the police rang the doorbell. And I opened it up. And it was two cops, a guy and a girl cop. And I asked the guy, is your weapon loaded? He said, why would you ask me something like that? I said, because I want you to shoot me in the head.
警察来了。我在里面。警察按了门铃。我打开门。是两个警察，一个男警和一个女警。我问那个男警，你的枪上膛了吗？他说，你为什么要问我那个？我说，因为我想让你对着我的头开枪。
I was just sitting in my bedroom. And I had my gun under my bed, in a sneaker box. I had a 40 Mag, big, old cowboy gun. And that's when my grandma caught the gun in my mouth. Yeah, she just opened the door to make sure I was cool. It just was one of them days. She opened the door, and gun in my mouth, you know what I mean?
我当时就坐在卧室里。我把枪放在床底下的鞋盒里。我有一把40口径的马格南，一把很大、很旧的牛仔枪。就在那时，祖母撞见我把枪塞进嘴里。是的，她只是打开门确保我没事。就是那样的日子之一。她打开门，我嘴里叼着枪，你懂我的意思吗？
She didn't know what to do. She didn't know to come closer or stay back. She didn't know what to do. So she looking at me, start whooping and crying. And she didn't want to come next to me. And so she's just talking to me the whole time, like, come on, baby, it's all right, I love you. You're my grandson. You know, your mom ain't leave you out here on the Earth for this. You blessed. You just got shot five times. Why are you?
她不知道该做什么。她不知道该走近还是后退。她不知道该做什么。所以她看着我，开始哀号和哭泣。她不想靠近我。所以她一直在跟我说话，比如，来吧，宝贝，没事的，我爱你。你是我的孙子。你知道，你妈妈把你留在地球上不是为了这个。你是被祝福的。你才刚中了五枪。你为什么？
It's going to be all right. We're going to get some help for you and everything. And I just took it out, decocked it, put it back in the box, and just sat there. And called my homie up, and bring some weed around the corner, and got high. And that's how that went.
一切都会好起来的。我们会为你找点帮助之类的。我只是把它拿出来，放下击锤，放回盒子里，坐在那里。打电话给我的兄弟，带点大麻过来，我就吸嗨了。事情就是这样发展的。
Both Brandon and Curtis have gotten help. Brandon's in AA and went through a writing program for veterans at NYU. Curtis is receiving counseling through the program at Drexel that offers help to guys coming off the street. But finally, it's here where their stories diverge. Brandon's tour ended, and he's now thousands of miles from the dangers of Afghanistan. Curtis still lives in his old neighborhood, where the danger's ongoing.
布兰登和柯蒂斯都得到了帮助。布兰登在参加戒酒互助会，并参加了纽约大学为退伍军人开设的写作项目。柯蒂斯正在通过德雷塞尔大学的项目接受咨询，该项目为脱离街头的人提供帮助。但最终，他们的故事在这里分道扬镳。布兰登的服役期结束，现在他离阿富汗的危险有数千英里之远。柯蒂斯依然住在他的老社区，那里的危险还在继续。
When I get more money, I'm definitely moving. I'm going to move. That's a priority I'm working on right now. I'm out. I'm going to live somewhere comfortable, that I know I can walk in the neighborhood, I could sit out there on my step all day, all night, if I want to.
当我赚到更多钱时，我绝对会搬家。我会搬走。这是我目前正在努力的优先事项。我要离开。我要住在一个舒适的地方，我知道我可以走在社区里，如果我想的话，我可以整天整夜坐在台阶上。
Not long ago, a guy was shot and killed down the block from where he lives. And Curtis happened to see the body on the ground.
不久前，一个家伙在他住的街区被枪杀了。柯蒂斯恰好看到地上的尸体。
And I just was thinking about a lot of the-- I was paused. I just was like, yo, when he shot, like, damn, that boy was on the ground. And that was me. It's just, I'm living. Like, he died. And I'm like, damn. And it just felt like I felt all them bullets all over again.
我只是在想很多……我暂停了。我只是像，哟，当他被射中时，就像，该死，那个男孩在地上。那是我。我活着。而他死了。我像是，该死。感觉就像我再次感受到了所有那些子弹。
Curtis worries that because of the way he walks, perpetually bent over, he looks weak and that people will target him, rob him, beat him up, shoot him, take revenge. I wonder, for someone like Curtis, if it's really post-traumatic stress, since really, there's nothing post about it.
柯蒂斯担心因为他走路的方式，总是弯着腰，他看起来很弱，人们会盯上他、抢劫他、殴打他、射击他、进行报复。我不知道，对于柯蒂斯这样的人来说，这是否真的是创伤后应激障碍，因为实际上，并没有什么“后”的事情。
Brandon, meanwhile, says he doesn't talk to his friends or family about his anger and his nightmares, which he still has regularly. He tried counseling, but didn't like it. So he sought out other veterans who understand what he's been through.
与此同时，布兰登说他不会跟朋友或家人谈论他的愤怒和噩梦，尽管他仍然经常做。他尝试过咨询，但没用。所以他寻找其他理解他经历的退伍军人。
And Curtis now attends group counseling with others who, like himself, were once running the streets. That's the final echo. They've both come to realize that they're not alone.
而柯蒂斯现在和那些像他一样曾经在街头混过的人一起参加团体咨询。这是最后一个共鸣。他们都意识到他们并不孤单。
Alex Kotlowitz.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨。
His books and documentaries include, most recently, the film The Interrupters, which he wrote and co-produced, which is at iTunes, Netflix, Amazon, and on DVD.
他的书和纪录片包括最近的电影《干扰者》，他编写并共同制作，在iTunes、Netflix、亚马逊和DVD上有售。
OK, so should we do the credits?
好的，那我们该录制作名单了吗？
Yeah, let's do it. Are you ready? God, you do this whole thing at the end of every show?
是的，让我们做吧。你准备好了吗？天呐，你每一集节目的结尾都做这个？
Yeah. OK. Ready?
是的。好的。准备好了吗？
You've got to hire someone to do that. (IMITATING IRA GLASS) Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek and myself--
你得雇个人来做那个。（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）嗯，我们的节目今天由米基·米克和我制作——
With Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、萨拉·科尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Our senior producer's Julie Snyder.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。
Production help from Tarek Fouda and Phia Bennin.
制作协助来自塔雷克·福达和菲亚·本宁。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Seth Lind is our operations director.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。
Emily Condon's our production manager.
艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）爱丽丝·伯格森是我们的行政助理。
Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
音乐协助来自达米恩·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Special thanks today to Jack Chen, Marissa Gillette, Katie Conner.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）今天特别感谢杰克·陈、玛丽莎·吉列特、凯蒂·康纳。
Mat Hannigan, Mike Reed, Chris Waldrup, Damien Graef, his kitchen crew, and everyone who ate the bung.
马特·哈尼根、迈克·里德、克里斯·沃尔德鲁普、达米恩·格拉夫、他的厨房工作人员，以及所有吃掉直肠的人。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Ted Corbin and Tony Thompson of the Healing Hurt People Program at Drexel University.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）泰德·科尔宾和托尼·汤普森，来自德雷塞尔大学的“治愈受创者”项目。
Nate Beaver, Amy Drozdowska.
内特·比弗、艾米·德罗兹多夫斯卡。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Eleanora Monticella, Kevin Miller.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）埃莱奥诺拉·蒙蒂切拉、凯文·米勒。
Zachary Sussman at NYU--
纽约大学的扎卡里·萨斯曼——
(BOTH) and Michelle Harris.
（两人）还有米歇尔·哈里斯。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Our website, where for the first time ever, you can watch the videotape of the Saturday Night Live dress rehearsal of me doing Ira Glass.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我们的网站，在那里你有史以来第一次可以观看我扮演艾拉·格拉斯的《周六夜现场》彩排录像带。
That address, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
地址是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）WBEZ的管理监督由我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责。
After a hard day at the radio station, he always declares on his way out the door--
在广播电台辛苦工作一天后，他在走出门口时总是宣布——
I'm Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And I'm Ira Glass.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我是艾拉·格拉斯。
He's actually Fred Armisen, by the way. Portlandia season 3, that's Friday nights?
顺便说一句，他其实是弗雷德·阿米森。《波特兰迪亚》第三季，是在周五晚上？
On IFC.
在IFC频道。
IFC season 3, back next week with more stories of
IFC第三季，下周回来，带来更多关于——
(BOTH) This American Life.
（两人）《美国生活》的故事。
[SAMMY DAVIS, JR., "ME AND MY SHADOW"]
（小萨米·戴维斯，《我和我的影子》）
OK, I think we're done. And I think we should cut.
好的，我想我们完成了。我想我们应该切断了。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) I think we are, I think-- are we OK?
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我想我们是，我想……我们还好吗？
I think we're OK.
我想我们还好。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) I'm not too worried about it.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我不太担心。
I think we got it.
我想我们做到了。
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) I wouldn't worry about it.
（模仿艾拉·格拉斯）我不会担心的。
Say, Frank?
说，弗兰克？
What is it, Sam?
怎么了，萨姆？
Would you do me a favor?
能帮我个忙吗？
What do you want now?
你现在想要什么？
Would you mind just taking it one more time?
你介意再来一次吗？
From the top?
从头开始？
No, from the ending.
不，从结尾开始。
Wonderful.
太棒了。
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI公共广播国际公司。